so we were walking the frozen river and
there was no sign of
a border whatsoever no wire bars no sign
one of our producers shouted soldiers
there were
two small soldiers with rifles chasing
us really fast
and then i was filming as i was running
reward or capture
you should go to my head i want to
survive what is the state of your mind
are you in shock i cannot believe we got
ourselves in a situation like this
what are you thinking in that moment
when you're with laura laura told me
you know where the enemies we were so
frightened but we're so calm as well at
the same time
how did you guys get rid of the footage
and the notes that you had we ate the
papers
the papers you ate it wow they were
trying to get all the information
including the sources that we met was
there any torture was there any
psychological torture was there fear
tactics
what did you experience during those 140
days a day felt like a ten year
did your opinion about north korea
change meaning did it get worse or did
it get better or just different
it was hard to separate the people of
north korea with government
you know you're a prisoner in north
korea for 100 old days but there are
people living in that whole country i
feel very
lucky
[Music]
so my guest today is yuna lee who is a
um best way to describe her as a
documentary journalist that
many years ago more like 11 years ago
she decided to go to do a documentary
with her friend her partner
in china and north korea and suddenly
they were arrested and they were in
prison for 140 days i let her tell you
the whole story
it got to the point where president
clinton and president obama had to get
involved
to help them bring him back to the
states a very touching story and this
was inspired
after having a conversation with janome
park many of you wanted to know more
about different point of views of north
korea and south korea so we decided to
reach out to you
and she was kind enough to say yes so
you know lee thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment
thanks for having me so i know it's been
a minute since this
event you know st patrick's day march i
want to say
17th of 2009 when you're out there
trying to shoot this documentary with
your partner i believe
laura is her name and many times when
you go through these types of
experiences most people don't want to
revisit it and keep telling the story
all over and over and over again
but uh you know sometimes uh
the man upstairs or whatever you believe
intends to use us in many different ways
to
either inspire educate or encourage
others in their own ways
and uh he you know and this has been you
that's been chosen to have this story
so i appreciate you agreeing to share
this story but for some of the viewers
that don't know the full story
of what happened there can you go back
and kind of tell us a little bit what
was the purpose of the documentary and
why did you guys choose to go to
north korea and china to shoot this and
how did this whole thing happen
um so before we
you know we i take you you guys to the
the later day of march 17th i want to uh
share how i ended up working on that
documentary
about human trafficking in china so it
was a 2005
i was working for current tv at the time
and i
got to know about documentary course
software it was about following it was
about
north korean defectors family for others
and young little toddler and they were
about to
uh enter the consulate a consulate
in china so because they were told that
if they crossed the gate
they would be safe and they made it
safely to china
and when they tried to cross the
consulate gate and then they stopped by
the chinese soldiers and there was a
young girl
who was standing confused and then
scared while watching her mom and
grandma was wrestling with the
chinese soldiers at the time i had
uh i just had a baby and she was 10
months old
whenever i came home uh whenever i held
my baby
it reminds me it reminds me of that
little toddler with pigtail
wow and i told my husband we gotta do
something about these people i
heard about north korean defectors uh a
dangerous journey
uh to escape their country and uh their
situation in north korea
but my life was busy as well so i kind
of uh
moved on and four years later 2009
i had finally had my own opportunity to
tell their stories
and there were some reports about how
numbers of north korean defectors
growing still
and their conditions especially for
female defectors
are really gotten worse in china
and they were prayed to be human
trafficking like they were sold to
uh farmer's wives inaudible workers and
sometimes they
were deceived when they crossed and they
didn't they don't even know
what uh they are facing when they cross
the border right
so my team and i were we traveled to
south korea and china to shed light on
their conditions
and it was a very important story to us
to tell the world because there are so
many stories out there
people don't know about we thought this
is one of the stories that people
need to pay attention to their condition
human rights in china
so that was march 17 was our last day
actually was filming
in china and we next day it was a day
that we were about to head to the u.s
so in the morning very early in the
morning we wanted to have the last
shooting
uh showing the border between china and
north korea
so we were at the north eastern china
where the
tuma river crossed between the countries
and that's
we're told that that's the route that a
lot of north koreans take
to escape and march 17
in that region is still freezing and
cold winter time
so river was still frozen so we were
walking the frozen river
and there was no sign of a border
whatsoever no wire bars
or no sign you don't know that if it's
the border
if we did we were not without fixer our
fixer
was pretty uh connected with the area
and unaware of the situation he
worked for nhk bbc on the same matter
before us so we completely trusted him
and when we were on
the frozen river maybe a few about 30
minutes or so
um filming the condition that how
freezing it was
and then where the you know this is the
route that a lot of north koreans taking
and one of our producers shouted
soldiers so i looked back and
there were two small soldiers with their
uniform with rifles chasing us really
fast
so we all ran towards chinese soil
as fast as we could one of our producers
man was
an avid runner so he disappeared fast
and um my fixer our picture was running
next to me
he was like you know are you filming
this
and i thought this is crazy but i
flicked my camera and put my own
underarms
and then i was filming as i was running
wow so while you're running you're
filming this entire event
you never know what kind of fridge
you're using you wanted to show the
condition right this is the moment that
this
uh the fear that a lot of north koreans
gonna face
and in my head just don't if you shoot
don't chew my head
i want to survive right and
when i was almost close to sinusoidal i
saw laura
lynn my colleague fell in front of me
and i stopped and she said
i can't i can't move my i can't feel my
legs
and i i didn't know what to do but i
knew that i couldn't
leave her there by herself she doesn't
speak the language
and then we were a team and
um our fixer was
and suddenly our fixture and me and
laura was surrounded by these two
soldiers
and we heard about this north korean
board
border guards that how you can simply
bribe them
even defectors they can pay them to
cross the
border or sometimes if you're
journalists
you can give them some cigarettes to
make a small talk
so our fixer was telling me the money
money so
just give them bribes and money to
escape that situation so i pulled that
or whatever in my pocket and
i gave to them and they did not want to
take it wow so
i knew something was going wrong and
when my fixture was not able to fix the
situation he ran as well
maybe he wanted to take one of soldiers
you know to
to from the situation i don't know but i
wanted him to run so that he can let
someone our situation sure
and now you know if you don't mind me
asking how many total are you even the
producer that's a very good runner how
many total people were you
yourself laura the fixer the producer
that's four how many more were there
good that was it
okay got it and
he i was wrestling with the um
uh the one of soldiers scratched laura
and the other surgeon grabbed me
and i saw laura was uh
fainted i didn't know that at the time
she was hit but she
was unconscious on the ice and
um the other soldier was uh
because i wasn't backing and you know i
was trying to yell
and screaming to get help from chinese
soil china
he raised his rifle to to hit me the
more taking the motion
and i looked at him and he was a
such a smaller he was a small boy maybe
or so and he was a hesitant to him me
at the time so i told him hey let me
walk with you
so i got up you're speaking in his
language when you're saying this to him
you're speaking in
korean yes i spoke korean to him and
we i got up and i crossed the river with
him
and that's how we ended up
being detained in north korea now if
laura couldn't walk would did the other
soldier carry her or how did laura get
there so i screamed
laura's name so many times and she
finally
woke up from conscious so we walked to
an army
and and did you later on in life figure
out why he didn't take the money from
you
i mean he he didn't try to take
advantage of you guys the two
two you know being two women there he
didn't try they didn't try to do that
they didn't try to take money did they
tell you why they didn't take money or
you never found out the answer to that
question
we we heard that the border security was
very tightened at the time
the the conditions and um
honestly don't know why they didn't take
money but
yeah very interesting so now you go
there
so at this point they don't seem
like to you they don't seem like they're
bad people you see them as
innocent young soldiers that are just
trying to do their jobs
these oh yeah yeah the these these were
just
uh like about my hair i'm only five two
they were like
my size and my eyes and then they were
somehow they were nervous nervous as i
we were i don't know why
and i had some like recorded tape in my
uh back then we used the tape small tape
so taking my pocket i had a small flip
phone
that i used to contact people in china
in my pocket so as they walked
us to an army the army base uh in my
head
i have to get rid of them
so i looked them and
they they were i don't know they were
just nervous they just
told us on top so i dropped i was able
to drop them one by one to get rid of
them
so that's that how much they were
nervous too
and when we arrived at the army base it
was uh
it was like a movie scene that i watched
it
from one of propaganda movie that i when
i grew up
in south korea it was a yard
they had a study call that soldiers
practice uh
knife fighting and
they had me stand there and laura
told me you know where the enemies
and the the flashy means that
that i watched from a movie that you
know the
people are tight in the pool and then
just being killed just flash it
but instead uh an officer tall guy
walked out of a small building um office
building
and he had a quote in his hand he handed
the code to me
and it's i did not realize i wasn't
wearing code at the time because
i had some phone numbers in my coat
pocket so
while i was wrestling with the soldiers
on the frozen river i got out of the
court
to leave that coat on the river and
my teeth were channeling but i was so
nervous that i didn't even realize and
then he had
miscourt so i was able to keep myself
warm
so that's a nice gesture from him that's
probably not expected to see something
happen like that
not at all because
at this point are you and laura
frightened are you
are you how i mean what is the state of
your mind are you in shock are you
meaning we i cannot believe we got
ourselves in a situation like this we're
about to go back to america we got all
the footage that we got
how do we find ourselves in this
situation what are you thinking in that
moment when you're with laura
we were so frightened but we're so calm
as well at the same time
and then you know i think i can speak
for her but i wanted to believe that
there is a chance that we can go back if
we talk to them some we can get out of
this situation somehow
and we talk to each other like let's
read all these slogans what he says and
remember all these
details you know because we were still
in the mode of making documentaries
so that we didn't know what was ahead of
us
but we were just at the moment that
we're still gonna we're gonna
finish these documentaries
so so while you're there i'm trying to
get so is it just you and laura
and the two are not with you the fixer
and the producers no longer with you
at the time i didn't know but laura had
a lot of michael and her when she was
captured and then she told our producers
keep running
so so they were don't don't come back
and then our fixer ran and we both
hoped that they would go somewhere to
report our situation
can you imagine like if we were or
captured
then no one would know where we would be
so
so so in a way the other two not getting
captured helped you get
uh free eventually because of them being
able to go away and telling people that
you guys were captured
i believe so i believe so and we had to
protect our sources as well the people
who we interviewed
who for them to run would protect them
as well in china and also
you know to help us uh situation now
what did you do with the footage was the
footage and the notes you took was it
with you how did you guys get rid of the
footage and the notes that you had
or was it with the producer and the
fixer so some of the
phrases that we filmed in south korea i
left with my family before we came to
china and some of the uh footages
we we found in china
was i heard that it's confiscated by
chinese police
but luckily when we met any
defectors in china we were very careful
filming there to to hide their identity
so we did not film their faces
did you i've read somewhere where you
guys the way you got rid of some of your
notes is you ate the paper did you guys
actually eat some of the notes or or or
is that uh
it's a pretty accurate statement i read
yeah it is uh
it seems like a long ago so faded in
a uh image but it was the first day that
we were captured
we were uh moved to another
from army base we moved to another place
we don't know where
and and they put us in a room
there were a sure moment that we were
just
ourselves so
i what i knew was i know that at some
point they're gonna find out what we did
but we need to have
uh keep it delayed as long as we can
so we rip the uh tapes that we had
we progressed it because these people
took the
camera that we filmed on the ice
they were figuring out what they what
how camera works and then you know what
they were in there
so we were with our physicians uh in the
room so we ripped the tapes
and then there were some memos that we
ripped it that that can be uh that has
uh uh one of sources uh
name so we ripped it i i gave a half to
laura and then half
we i told laura to eat it and we ate you
ate the tape
no we ate the papers the papers you ate
it wow
did they ever during that 140 days find
out that you were documentary
journalists or they never found out
they they did they did not find it out
for for a couple of days
we told them we were a student film
student and then we followed a professor
to just film the border we were
reporting about the economy situation at
the border
and they didn't figure it out they had a
very limited uh
people speak english but they were able
to figure things out they
uh interrogated laura and they separate
and then
the sum of numbers did not match and
then
laura in english we were um
they put us uh in cells next to each
other
laura was actually asking you know
should we tell them
and we we we just wait a little bit
wait a little bit and then until the
moment that we had to tell them that we
are from current tv
the day uh so so while you're there the
140 days
what what what experience did you have
was there any
torture was there any psychological
torture was there fear tactics
what did you experience during those 140
days
the the one thing that really surprised
me was these people
i grew up in south korea so north korea
was always annoying to us
we grew up with these very animated uh
stories that how
norse grand theft auto brutally killing
people innocent people during the court
of during the korean war and
hearing the story about young south
korean boy being brutally killed by
north korean soldiers because he said he
doesn't have communists
so they were a very scary figure to me
but whoever i met not everybody was
scared here they some of them had very
kind eyes
and it don't get me wrong you know when
we were moved to the capital city of
pyongyang
long interrogation they had very still
tactics to just break our
you know psychologically break us down
so it was a
long psychological better and difficult
time but
even during that time i was able to find
some human kindness
humanity in those people
what was it more uh uh because the way
you
uh describe it it doesn't sound like it
was that bad of 140 days it just sounds
like you were in jail
so did you have terrible experiences or
was it just
pleasant experiences you had there oh
you cannot be pleasant experience
that's why i was asking that because you
know from and the reason why i'm asking
this question is because
you know for the viewer we don't know
north korea
uh because we've not been there right
obviously we had the anami park she gave
a whole different perspective
and then we hear what we hear in the
news and how
uh close north korea is with china and
china has north korea's back and not a
lot of countries
trust north korea and you hear human
trafficking you hear all these other
things torture all these things you hear
about
and if you look at all the countries in
the world the darkest country in the
world with lights
is north korea and for someone like you
that's there
visually it's it helps the world
audience especially since we have 190
different countries plus that follow the
content here
it helps for them to get a little bit
more educated on what happens in some of
these prisons
of north korea for us to get educated so
if you could give us the
humane side of what it was where the
people or the people is different than
the government
and and the torture side or the
challenge
what are the two polar opposite sides
for us to get a better perspective what
would that be
i think because because we were foreign
journalists and then
there were us very slight slings of
chance that
they would send us back home i think
they were careful with us
what we can see what we cannot see so
in at the border when we are in the cell
it was just a regular cell that anybody
just seen like
maybe they just sell that north korean
defectors like would go in there too
so it was a poor condition did not have
the bathroom condition was horrible and
just food was
just poor we received a small
vegetable like cabbage dish with a
porridge that i don't even know if
it was rice or it was a corn
that was a condition true condition but
when we moved to
when we moved to pyongyang it
luckily i was putting in a place that
it's like i guess the house
had a place with a bedroom and right
next to
it was a guard room but
even it doesn't matter where you are uh
put it in you are
what you're a prisoner watched 24 7 by
guard
and then they were recorded every
conversation that had
with me or any of my activities and
as you know us does not have a
diplomatic relations with north korea
so i was not able to visit it i mean no
one was able to visit me
for 140 days except the swedish
ambassador
who visited us i think maybe twice and
it was
about 10 minutes each time so
i dealt with the the four words
every day and you know how your life was
goes by so fast here we're so busy with
all this kind of information
there a day felt like a ten year
yeah and
yes they did not hit me physically
and i'm very i feel very lucky
but that's just me i know
so many testimonies out there
from those grand defectors how
physically they were
harmed and abused
and whenever i received a single meal
the
it was rice and soup and some fried uh
fish and vegetables very simple meal but
even that i was so thankful because i
know so many north koreans
were not even getting those kind of
meals
now the 140 days while you're there
are you and laura in the same room or no
you and laura are not seeing each other
at all
no after we knew
we were next to each other when we were
at the border cell
when they moved us to pyongyang in the
middle of the journey
they separated us and i we didn't know
we were not going to see each other
until we came home
you knew that already that you're not
going to see each other you come home
and did they use manipulative tactics to
pin you guys against each other or laura
said this
oh yuna said this oh laura said this oh
she already told us the truth
or you know were they using those
stories to pin you guys against each
other or no
they did they did a pretty good job on
it it's uh
they were trying to get all the
information including the sources that
we met
in china but luckily laura does not
speak
korean so she couldn't pronounce
anybody's name correctly
and at the time i knew just one guy's
name very clearly
but i would not really said his name
because i knew that she
couldn't she doesn't she didn't know his
name and
the rest of them it was a i was in
social mode
that i couldn't even remember the
details even though they repeatedly need
to say this and that and i
just couldn't remember the details
so they did not get much out of us that
that is
uh that is fascinating that she did now
laura ling was she
born in the states i know you were born
in south korea was she born in the
states
i believe so yeah okay got it and you
were born in south korea
and how old were you when you came to
the states or you left south korea
uh 24 i pretty much grew up in south
korea
so yeah and your reasoning for leaving
was to
go to the art school i believe right to
come out here and go to art school and i
think even eventually well
recently after you got out in 2012 i
think you got a degree from columbia
university i believe
yeah so um well i started film because
even when i was young i knew that the
film has good uh
powerful impact on people's lives and i
so some of the
people who made the story about
a mascara in south korea in 1980s in one
city that was
really the people were killed by uh
armies
but the street didn't uh was not going
out
so those films
was going like we this group actually
projected this film in
colleges in late 80s
and then they were chased by police
officers because of the directions
so i knew how much impact that film can
make and
slowly that when i came here after i
came here i got a job at a tv
uh station and i wanted to do something
more
rewarding i i didn't know what that was
and then the documentary
came to the opportunity came to to me
it's still today documentary production
isn't
isn't there is many opportunities for
documentary journalists
and that was we're very lucky to have
that opportunity
and um yeah that's how i ended up
working on documentaries
after 2000 instant i
kept thinking that what did i do wrong
what did i just wrong
well how could i have made it better and
that
brought me to decide to go to uh the
you know the best journalism school in
the us so i studied
geology at columbia it's very impressive
i mean it
doesn't get better than that it's one
the best of the best out there people
who know the world it's a
great school to go to now you know for
somebody that lived in south korea for
two i lived in iran for 10 years and i
remember going to school
and all i heard a million times was
married battle and recalled married bad
umbrica which is
death upon america and america was the
worst
country in the world they hated people
they hated iran they bullied everybody
it was all these bad things i always
read about iran right
growing up in school in south korea a
free nation you're not necessarily
dealing with you know all the other
things that north korea deals with
i think there was an army base in korea
called camp casey a lot of
our soldiers used to go to camp casey
but when you were growing up in
south korea in school cartoons education
history
how did south korea's educational system
and media
paint america how do they paint russia
how do they paint
china and how do they paint north korea
i'm curious
oh i you know actually i don't really
remember how they painted about other
countries like iran
and china back then but north korea was
hardly mentioned on news at the time
negro
it was only the top propaganda like
education taught
in schools that how we have to be
careful about the north korean spies
still out there we need to report to
police we made the posture
about how we can protect our country
from north korea
because they went through korean wars
and they did not want us
to go through another war
north korea and south are technically
under army states right since
korean war ended in 1953
so it doesn't mean that we're spending
where peace we're still it's under army
so that's the education that we received
and about america i think they have the
two different views about america
some people really appreciate america's
health for korean war
and some people blames america that the
korean
division was because of american and
russians involvement
that's how much i remember that's how
much you remember when you were there
got it so so why do you think you said
the media didn't say anything about
north korea but education did
is that what you were saying that media
wasn't talking bad things about north
korea but educational system was
it was just not we did not really talk
here about north korea
media like two days but you hear about
north korea all the details
there are so many defectors about 30 000
defectors
living in south korea now they clearly
speak about human rights violations in
north korea
and some people who speaks english
english calling out international
attention on uh north korean defector
situation in china
so so for you when you went through the
140 days of being there did any of your
opinion about north korea change
oh i'm sorry patrick can you repeat it
again yes when you went to north korea
and you were there for 140 days i mean
in the military jail all these
other places and you know your
you know all these things that they're
doing to you did your opinion about
north korea change meaning did it get
worse or did it get better or just
different it it's uh
different i so i kind of uh
understood where they're coming from and
why they
hate south korea so much why they hate
the us so much
and that's something that similar
experience that i had that growing up
south korea that
they taught propaganda towards uh south
korea as well
so i understood where they're coming
from at the same time i felt
very sad for the people in north korea
because
they're getting limited edited
information so the information they're
receiving from their government
is partially true and then partially
incorrect
and that's uh it was something that
unbelievable
for me to see that these people are
watching the news
about uh uh an older lady
blind lady open her eyes because after
drinking some
drink from their leader and
who would believe that story and these
people are watching this kind of
news stories and they believe it they
watch about
how horrible economic situation and
affordable human condition in south
korea
and western countries that's what they
believe in
that's how much they know
when when you were in south korea and
there was 30 000 you said 30 000
defectors today i don't know the exact
number when you left because you lived
there 24 years that's a long time to
live over there
24 years did you have any friends that
were defectors did you have any uh
classmates that were defectors did you
have any peers you were spending time
with that were defectors
oh you did not nobody it wasn't i've
been being numbered
uh you know you have to have a broker
nowadays
to escape north korea at that time it
wasn't a big
big deal even 2004 there weren't many
2009 there weren't many numbers
who said it in south korea there were
some studies that
from international organizations and
news reports said that there were about
150 to 300 000 north korean defectors
living in china
but none of the number was just you can
really say which number is correct
but until 2019
there are about a little bit over 30 000
north korean defectors
settled in south korea did you have any
friends and co-workers and classmates
that
escaped north korea to come live in
south korea that you
befriended no it would be very rare
situation
if even if they escaped north korea in
certain ways that they would be quiet
so i had no friends who came from north
korea
but uh after after i came home
i made some friends uh defective north
korean defectors
did they change your mind at all about
north korea or did it make you
uh see even the uglier side that they're
you know
maybe hiding from the populace because
one of the things that you said which
was very interesting
is when you went to the prison the 140
days that you were there they didn't
really combine you with other prisoners
because
if they were by any chance gonna free
you they didn't want you to have that
story to go back and tell the world so
when you did get a chance to spend some
time with some of the defectors
did you sit there and say i cannot
believe the atrocities that
uh the government it's you know passing
down to the people
did you experience that hearing the
stories no
actually we never really talked about
north korea when we sat together
but you know how more like you know how
we can help these people
like to uh
the situation better not people in north
korea but people in uh
in china uh that's something that we
we talk about but it's not about like
north korean government because we
already were known
even though i did not have that
experience i read so many stories
uh from north korean defectors what they
faced
when they are when they when chinese
government
forced them back with patriotism
on them they would face they would go to
labor camps
educational camp or political camps some
are executed
so we we already know the story that how
horrible situation they would put it in
if they are captured in china
and sent back to north korea oh so a lot
of the folks from north korea that
escaped to china didn't want to tell
anybody because if they were captured
the chinese government would send them
back to north korea
that is the problem because chinese
government even though
international law and experts and then
international organizations seized the
north korean defector situation as
the refuge category of the un's
convention in relation to their
refugee status china denies to give them
refugee status asylum
status so and they see them as a labor
immigrant so they would send back to
north korea where they face
persecutions it's what i experienced
myself as well a lot of people that were
escaping iran that came to the states i
even remember ayatollah khomeini telling
the
carter that hey send back the shot to
iran we'll take care of them and they
wouldn't want to do it because
they were going to experience
persecution a lot of the people that
were baha'i religion
they were being found and a lot of bad
things happened to them there was a
even a comedian in germany that was
found in this hotel room far
i believe that that's his last name but
the story is a pretty ugly story what
they did to them so i wouldn't be
surprised but
if if you don't mind continuing the
whole 140 days
you know some other experiencing leading
to the end of it
is there any other thing that's visual
that sticks to you till today
that you're comfortable sharing with the
rest of us something that actually
um i remember is because of the north
korean
that is portrayed on media maybe not
nowadays anymore
but back then they were like a robotic
people
like we we've seen people like crying
group people crying for
uh at the uh for their leader staff
and then we just uh don't understand
that how someone somebody can
the person can be so royal to this
leader or
this country and they were we thought
they were very robotic people
but in some way that the people were
like people human and i saw whenever i
saw people like making smaller chats or
a smiling and have a smile on their
faces
that was something that like drying
moments
to me i i don't think i understood
what what do you mean by that the
smiling faces
it's uh yeah i would not think that
there was a smile naturally
you know if they would smile when their
tortoise smile they would cry when their
tortoise smile
i didn't think they have a uh free
free to express themselves but they were
a moment that i saw that they
had a free expressions and that was that
told me that
they were human like us that's when i
stopped the humanities
humanities then is that the moment where
you spend some time with the two guards
the
guard a and guard b the two ladies
that so of moments that i i spent time
and some moments that i spent with my
interrogators
and some of the scenes that i watched on
tv
and i had a very small limited access to
interact with people
but even that that's that's the sense
that i received in guards
they often ask me like how do you
pronounce this
she studied in english and that's
another thing that i was surprised
because uh
um back when i was young then i i
was told that north korea didn't does
not teach people english because
the u.s is their enemy right so they
were running russian
as a second language but
what i saw was people were very
interested in learning english because
it's
international language they wanted to be
part of international
so they were learning english and
discard was
they were singing i don't know if they
were trained or planned to sing
they were singing a song some indians my
heart would go on
and those are the moments that like wow
you know did i think that
the north koreans were a
did i have to stereotype nursery did i
equated north korean people with
this government north korean government
too much
did i equate the north korean people
with the north korean government are you
trying to say
that maybe the north korean government
was
vicious and uh you know
no lack of accountability or concern for
human rights while the
human the the people of north korea were
regular people like you and i
is that kind of what you're saying you
found a way to differentiate between the
two
yes uh you're correct you are correct
even though we see no screen as a regime
and then the the
future country and has no human right
you know has human rights violation all
the time in the country but
people are people the policy is towards
north korea we
we can't forget about that there are
people living in that country
do you think sometimes the way the media
pins
north korea makes us look at all north
koreans that way
is that what you think happens sometimes
i am amazing
i grew up like that you know watching
and reading about north korea that
it was it was hard to separate the
people of north korea with government
so so at what point did you when when
you were going through this 140 days
at what point did you hear that you're
going to get sentenced for 12 years
when when was that moment when you got
word you're going to get 12 years of
labor
how did that happen so after about three
months of interrogations
uh we were asked
that there will be a trier and the
north korean government actually offered
me a lawyer
that if i want to use their lawyer and i
refuse to use a lawyer and um
it was about three days prior and at the
end of the trial it was
june 3rd i believe that they sent ben
fit
me for 12 years in labor camp
12 years in labor camp and when when
that news was
given to you what was your reaction and
were you and laura together when you
were told 12 years
we were in the courts together it
doesn't mean that we're talking to each
other but yes and that was the first
time that i
really crashed it and i held a pretty
strong
poncho that moment and whenever 12 years
i i didn't think that i would just
i could survive for 12 years i was
already physically still weakened and
then
just thinking about not seeing my
daughter
at the time she was born for 12 years
and i just couldn't i just couldn't
handle it so i
crashed it on the ground and then cried
i didn't care who's watching me but
i cried really loud you know
it seems like you didn't want to show
any weakness to these folks for 140
days why is that i
i thought if uh i think that's the part
of
that's a probably same as i didn't know
uh
if i become weak i thought that i'm
giving up hope assumes of hope so i had
to be strong and then hopeful
then there is a every day i felt like
it's a
one day closer to go home that was uh
that that's how i stayed strong
until they told me 12 years
so when they told you 12 years did you
at that point have the ability to make
any phone calls or no that was it you're
going back to
work and you know do what you do or how
quickly did you get some good news
uh it was regarding the 12 years
either it was june 3rd and 24th that i
heard it was 12 years
and then they were i heard that they
were discussing
um that where labor camp that they're
going to send i think they were in
discussion
because the interrogator
he the interrogator who told me that
uh that you might be together with laura
or one day king you know story is
different and
but we came on on august
uh fours so two months for two months
they were still discussing the weather
what what
whether they're gonna actually send us
to the labor camp or i don't know
but we were i was just praying that when
i get out of this place
i'll go home not a labor camp
because the labor camp the stories
is just under
human conditions and i already learned
about from the vector stories
so i couldn't see myself surviving in a
labor camp
what what did you hear that happen at
the labor camps exactly
there are hardly any food and then you
do the hard labors for
all day and some people because of the
lack of food that they usually see some
people
even just to catch mouths and like
they try to survive themselves in mouths
and things like that
so um and they they say that they see
people dying
in their cells and some people don't
even care because they're so hungry and
starving
and when they receive food your person
next to you
just died and then you to get that food
to eat because you're hungry
that's uh that's the kind of story then
that i heard over and over
uh how did the news get delivered to you
that you're gonna be free and being able
to come back home
so i was lucky
to receive some letters from home of
course there's no news about
me coming home but i i learned that
how a lot of people were working on our
cases that you know raising voices
you can see in the back here back a
banner that i
um kept it from 2009 it was from one of
details that people
wrote messages to us that stay strong so
that was a message that i received from
home
and north korean uh government did not
even tell us until we come home that
we're going to go home
they the day before we came home they
told us that you have a visitor
from the u.s
and very high officer teacher and then
i asked the guy who delivered the
message i asked him is there
a way to is this moving forward or is
this the way it tends to go backwards
and he said oh i think it's moving
forward so i knew that was there
something that
good things going on and they took that
was the first day
that um except the except at the
corridor he said that was the first that
i met
with laura and that we were able to talk
and then they sent us a hotel it was a
korean hotel and then they had us wait
in the room for
over an hour and i talked to laura and
who
thank you who visited us and i told her
if i just
she goes maybe jimmy carter or this is
you know it would be
anderson we told we talked about all the
names that we
we knew who's to associate with north
korea we bill clinton wasn't president
bill clinton wasn't even on the list
and and i told her i don't think i would
recognize jimmy carter if i had
president jimmy carson there you know
it's
his or the image that i remember is an
old picture and
and they finally told us that you're
gonna go to that room
and when we went to a room there were
some people with uh
not korean people with the earpiece and
then standing
around so we knew that okay somebody was
very important here
and there were two double doors and they
opened the double door there was a
president clinton standing with uh his
gray hair
had a big like the window that had the
light
backdrop on him and uh and he looked
like an enter to me
so he opened his arms and we ran towards
him
and um he gave us a hug and he asked us
if well
we're doing okay physically doing okay
he told us that you know
[Music]
i can't promise anything at this moment
but i will if we go
we'll be able to be on the plane
physically and we we told him like of
course i'm not gonna say no yeah yes yes
and we saw him meeting uh north korean
liver at the time kim jong
il and on the news
and so kim jong-il kind of had a smile
on his face on those pictures
so we thought oh something's going on
something's
getting better it's getting better and
laura was excited and i was excited at
the same time too
we're still in the same room and i i
told her let's not open the champagne
batter yet
i so i kept praying and kept praying
until
about four in the morning they told us
pack our stuff
and then we went we were pardoned and we
went to the airport
get on the plane what point did you
fully feel free
like did you feel free at that moment
when you were pardoned or when the plane
took off and when you were on the plane
were you on the plane with president
clinton or you were on a separate plane
no we were on the plane with the
president clinton and his team
and he had uh
he he asked us if we want to make funko
to home uh
to family so we're sitting on the uh
north korean soil and we i made a phone
call to my husband and i told him again
i'm the plane with president clinton
he goes don't no don't call me back when
you're in the air
so he did not want to open the champion
yet
until the plane takes off so i called
him back after playing takes off
and then i finally felt everything felt
so surreal you know you're a prisoner
in north korea for 140 days and next day
you are in a private chat with the
president clinton
and everything that is so surreal
when you land and you're getting off the
plane and you see uh the picture of your
daughter
hugging you in that moment what do you
what are you thinking are you do you
still remember it till today
can you go to that emotion till today to
know what it felt like to hold your
daughter again
yeah of course that was uh the moment
that
makes me really emotional but the
happiest moment at the same time
um i
when i
well to her i thought
that she would recognize me right away i
didn't know how much the four months
would do to this four-year-old girl
and she looked very confused so i opened
my arms
and hannah can you give me a hug it's
mommy
and she gave me a hug and then that's uh
that's the moment that i felt like i
wanted this moment so badly
i wanted to hold my baby so badly and
yeah i mean when you watch it you know
your daughter you you know that was
she's 15 now your daughter had four
she was hanging on to like glue you
couldn't separate her from
you the way she was hugging you it's
very emotional as a parent
watching that moment uh what it felt
like for you
uh and your husband being there and it's
just a
it's a fascinating story to see you guys
decide to
your story of you wanting to get into
film because
you want to make impact and you choose
documentary which at a point where it's
not really a lot of jobs to do it's
tough to make money and documentary to
hire people
and you have the privilege of doing that
and you take a project like this and
right before coming to the states you
guys get captured
uh uh it's a powerful story you know
uh as you as you look back now
that was 2009 to tune out to now
a lot's changed you know it's a
different world we're living in today
than 2009
and when things like this happen to you
you know sometimes it makes us want to
research a topic a little bit more
because we're so close to it when a
kid grows in a foster home in the ages
he kind of wants to find a way to give
back to foster kids when
somebody is raised in a domestic
violence environment and the son sees
daddy
abusing mom that son wants to do
something for domestic violence you know
when somebody experience
human rights they want to give back for
human rights
where you're at right now and what you
experience what is your opinion now
about kim young own and north korea
you mean the the current leader of kim
jong-un current leader yes
forgive my pronunciation so i may have
pronounced it wrong but yes the current
leader
what what am i what's my opinion about
kim jong-un
um there are news about him that how
he's
uh he to be honest with you
um it's not because of uh i had the
experience
with uh um because of my experience in
north korea it doesn't mean that i
follow the north korean news every day
it's more like i do feel responsible for
people in north korea
and people who we met for the interview
for the documentaries because
because we never had a
documentary released as we
uh promised although our case that told
the bigger story about nurse grandfather
situation but that there are some parts
for me to
feel guilty that i
did not need to admit their promise
and but for
the countries it doesn't mean that i was
following the news on the north korean
leaders and north
and the contr the the current situation
i don't think their situation is better
better than 10 years ago even though
north korea has a different tactics
right now they have
youtube channels to connect with the
viewers they know that how
their country has been seen in a dark
the way that it's human rights
violations and dark you know economic
conditions and people are starting
so they don't want to show those kind of
words so what they're doing is now they
are they want to refresh their image
so they have a youtube channel showing
that how a wonderful pyongyang is
all those things but that's a pyongyang
we all know that pyongyang is a
if you're a citizen living in pyongyang
you're a special citizen
but what about what about the rest of
the countries that people living
and um i heard about the sanctions
making their economy conditions more
difficult and people are starting to
having difficult times so
i on and off i think about them and then
you know my job is continue to produce
stories that
that the true information the liberty
information
for the people who are in the place and
countries like north korea otherwise
they can get the truth
and part of the reason that i work for
voice of america is because uh the
korean
service was starting to tv
team in 2017.
the day they produced news for people in
north korea
and that's a part of the reason that i
decided to work for voice of america
and now i don't i no longer will be able
to create the korean service
but it's a broader aspect that i will
continue to
you strategize the videos efforts
for voice of america so we continue to
provide this information for not only
people in north korea but people
in countries like iran china
and russia other otherwise they wouldn't
get the truth
you know you know forgive me if if i'm
wrong here
uh and i'm if i'm wrong just say pat
you're absolutely wrong
i i get a feeling you you hold back a
little bit
going against north korea where
you're either being extra careful
or you're you're almost not
wanting to kind of uh say anything bad
uh against the uh regime of north korea
am i wrong or is there a little bit of
hesitation on your end
no you it's not no i don't i don't
have a hesitation but what i'm careful
is i don't
i don't want because of what we
created news out there i don't want
people to forget about people
living in north korea you know of course
we have to throw a destination of course
we have to
stop the regime to to test missile all
these things
but you know like iran then when there
was sanction on iran
what i heard from iranian people friends
what they're saying is that the
people suffer the food suffered is not
government
it's a people so that's what i'm careful
about
when i say something towards north korea
i don't want people to
forget about you know when you focus on
the government how horrible this
government is
but there are people living in that
horrible country
uh so so you're referencing the fact
that
sanctions are what made the conditions
bad in north korea and iran not
necessarily the government is is that
kind of what you're insinuating or no
no that's uh one of course
um i'm just exampling sanctions because
sanctions you you're from iran and
sanctions on iran and north korea
are similar situations but
what we need to be that's the
politics that's politics the government
the government but the
for the human level that we have to
think about
people
yeah no i i fully agree but you know
what do you do with a government that's
not that doesn't prioritize human rights
that doesn't value human rights that
doesn't uh
look at people as any kind of value do
you just
let them do everything you can in your
power or do you impose sanctions
for them to know that you can't go
abusing people like this your entire
life we have to find a way to have some
kind of a revolutionary regime change
because if it continues people's lives
are going to be continuously taken so
what do you do about it do you just sit
on the sidelines and watch it happen
or do you find ways i don't have an
answer for
answer patrick and then you know that
i'm not saying that we just let them
abuse people right the government abuse
people
and um while governments are
you know doing their part i think there
are people
as journalists we have our job to do it
as well
we will continue to report you know
about human rights
violation in the countries we don't stop
reporting about
the conditions but what i am
you you mentioned that i'm being careful
about
about talking about north korean
government it's not because uh
i agree with what they're doing it's
because
i'm careful because what the word
i don't want people to have same
experience without what i had i
i i dehumanitize them
when i grew up in south korea i heard
about so many news about north korean
government
that there was no people in my mind
maybe i don't understand what you mean
by that so are you are you saying that
even the powerful people
in the government that are seeing evil
even deep down inside they're good
people where they there are people like
you and i is
is that what you're saying just average
people that's what i'm saying because
we the powerful people that we are so
focusing on
we forget about the people average
people you know the question then
becomes what do you do for these guys
you know how do you how do you help them
you know
i mean the media has to do their best to
do what they do but then
what do governments do i lived in iran
and you know i
i wish the iranian revolution would have
never happened because i would still be
living in iran
i wish there was uh uh because the
moment the revolution in iran happened
conditions in iran got worse a half a
million people died in war that
shouldn't have happened we didn't need
to have a war like that but
unfortunately things changed in iran
when carter came and visited and he left
right after he left the revolution
started in iran and it cost a lot of
people's lives
and you know these kinds of memories
they stay you know because you
experience it firsthand so you so you so
you think about it and you remember it
from that perspective
so do you think just last question on
this topic here do you think
the approach being taken from other
countries around the world towards
countries like north korea
china and iran is the right way to go
about this with sanctions or do you
think there's better ways to go about it
[Music]
um
it's a you can never find the right like
the perfect answer for it governments
make that decision because they believe
saying that
it is uh the right decision right
and um i think history will tell
and at the end that later
later that if it was working or not
so i do something at the end called
speed round i'll give you a name
so what are your thoughts when you think
about bill clinton
my rescuer your rescuer i bet of course
uh what do you think about when you
think about uh barack obama
one word it has a heart for
uh average person like me okay very cool
what do you think about trump
trump trump he communicates
on social media okay good that's a safe
answer how about kim jong-un
kim jong-un is a a young
mind leader that once made change of
north korea but did not make
change much okay and then biden
was running against trump who's running
against trump you know you should
consider
politics because you're very political
with your answers
i think you could you could have a
career in politics but look
more than anything else uh uh i
um i'll give you the final thoughts you
know with with everybody watching
everything
and seeing what's going on with the
current conditions in the world today
what are your final thoughts thinking
what the future is going to be
for folks who are living in north korea
and how we can uh or what we can do you
know positive thoughts positive for you
know
outlook on what could potentially happen
in the future with the folks in north
korea
um you know like i recently worked on a
history uh
history uh pilot that was about ballin
wong
that how it collapsed
because of the collectible will of young
people
i know it's so hard for north korean to
have
collective voices because they are
watching each other
but one day i hope that they will be
able to have a corrected voice they will
be able to have a will
to have to find better freedom
i love that and i hope they get a chance
to see this to have your point of view i
know it's been 11 years since the event
but uh every once in a while it's good
to be reminded of history and things
that have been taking place and
i appreciate you being willing to relive
that moment for the last hour
and give us a different perspective of
what it was like to be a political
person i'm not even a political person
but be a prisoner for 140 days
and eventually be free so uh yuna lee
again thank you for your time we're
going to put the link below to your book
for anybody that wants
your book you can go to the link below
and be able to order her book
the stories are even deeper in her book
i know it's been 11 years but she gives
a completely different optic
on what she experienced and with that
being said you know again thank you for
making the time for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you so much patrick so different
than jonami parks interview that i did a
few weeks ago where she was a defector
escaping north korea at 13 years old she
goes to china
and she becomes a slave she gets sold
for two three hundred dollars and
finally goes to south korea eventually
finds her way here
but here's a story of somebody that was
in south korea for 24 years comes to the
states decides to do a documentary with
her friend laura
and they go up there they're about to
finish it up they get arrested 140 days
and they're supposed to do 12 years of
labor hard labor
and they eventually are set free and she
meets president clinton and she comes
back to the states
when you heard this perspective of her
story
i'm curious to know what your biggest
takeaway was i actually am to know
from you what your biggest takeaway was
from her point of view
as somebody shooting a documentary did
it change anything
on your thoughts about human rights
about north korea about south korea
about china
anything of what she said if yes comment
below and if you have not yet seen
the interview with jonami park where she
gave a speech
nine years ago or eight years ago in two
days she got 50 million views
when she gave that speech at a young age
and then we had a chance to do a
follow-up interview with her if you've
not seen that yet
it's very powerful click over here to
watch that interview and if you've not
subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye